les centres la dette par le travail
permettent aux adultes handicapées de
pratiquer une activité professionnelle
le centre du droit et celui de mauro car
écueil en tout 200 ha du genre les seat
est dépendant de l'adapei pourtant on
affiche complet
le renouvellement à l'intérieur même des
seat et est très limité et seat est
partie intégrante de la vie économique
celle-ci s'étant emprise il récupère des
travaux de sous-traitance en plus en
revanche intégrer un jeune handicapé
dans la vie professionnelle normale est
de plus en plus difficile la conjoncture
actuelle conjoncture économique actuelle
nous permet que difficilement de sortir
des adultes de notre établissement non
pas parce que il ne pourrait pas le
faire car il ya certains adultes
handicapés je crois nous aussi a t qui
pouvait éventuellement sortir dans une
entreprise de travail normales mais bon
le les chefs d'entreprise ne sont pas
tout à fait disposé à recevoir des
adultes handicapés je crois pour le
moment je pars la conjoncture et puis de
par la crainte de devoir imposer aux
gens qui travaillent en entreprise un
adulte handicapé éventuellement alors
que je pense que si on visite les
établissements de travail protégé sans
compte que les gens sont capables ça
faisait bien travaillé réaliser des
choses intéressantes si la raison de
fond et économique le malaise actuel et
financier chez seat et fonctionne avec
des prix le jour n'est octroyée par le
département
celui ci n'a pas la possibilité
d'augmenter nos blocs ses locaux vides
représente pourtant une solution un peu
loose et la dette pays haïti le château
et compte en faire un seat et une
subvention de l'état est promise mais la
faible augmentation du budget du conseil
général rigueur gouvernementale oblige
ne permet pas de nouvelles dépenses
sommes en relation du chemin avec le
grand général et nous espérons que ce
qui n'a pas été possible
en 1983 le sera au budget
184 compte tenu du besoin qui est connu
de tout le monde qui a fait l'objet
d'une part donc nous nous avons des noms
de personnes à accueillir mais au niveau
de la région et du département on
connaît les places qui devraient ils
sont nécessaires d'ici trois ans
maintenant puisque dans le tête qui a
été fait il ya deux ans faisait
ressortir 150 pour le département
on
l'adapei a donc besoin de moyens pour
investir dans de futurs locaux la
traditionnelle opération brioches pourra
peut-être de permet de faire face à
l'avenir